26 de outubro de 2005 em viena na
áustria
tinha cinco mil pessoas eu tinha sete
minutos falando espanhol era o meu
discurso da vida naquele grande público
eu tinha responsabilidade de representar
o brasil
de representar o continente americano e
na metade do meu discurso microfone
falhou o deus porque comigo porque não
foi a minha concorrente palhaçada é essa
eu tive que tomar uma decisão muito
rápida e naquele momento sempre pedindo
entendendo que a coragem dos outros é
importante pra mim que um grupo de
brasileiros com a camisa do brasil super
discreta e eu consegui olhar rapidamente
para eles e fiz a hora que falhou física
e aí e eles até então estavam dando
assim quando um batismo aos olhos deles
fizeram se o gol pelo gol ele peraí
eu respirei de dois passos sorri e eu
continuei o gol e fiquei gigante naquele
palco em que me segurava aquele momento
fez história e naquele momento eu fui
subindo realmente meu degrau para a
mínima e eu não imaginava que
conseguiria um lugar mais alto ea
oratória me trouxe aqui é o lugar mais
alto onde eu fui pela primeira vez
aplaudida onde pela primeira vez eu não
deixei ninguém decidir por mim era um
medo do outro não era meu
eu fiquei gigante transformou
mas eu queria mais eu percebi que essa
atitude de coragem que eu tive foi uma
decisão que eu tomei antes do concurso
de oratória sim porque nessa vitória
coragem em ação coragem vai ter um
conceito de coragem de enfrentar medo
medo coragem em ação eu percebi aqui nos
quebra-cabeça do tek que toda essa minha
coragem
aquelas minhas maiores fraquezas a minha
maior do amigos meus maiores traumas de
infância o que eu não gostava em mim eu
transformei força e isso realmente foi a
minha grande virada começaram tudo pra
minha infância muito bullying saracura
perna fina uma guerra pé todos possam
objetivo você pode imaginar e bullying o
phd em bullying né muito trauma na
escola eu odiava educação física ou java
apresentar trabalho porque eu não tinha
grupo não tinha vida social na escola
era o terror mas não era o suficiente em
casa tinha um outro situação a mesma
amiga amante a fã clube pe
a minha mãe era top da galáxia a minha
mãe levava multidões não era mais a mais
simpática mas falante mais interativa
mas mais e eu era menos memória luz
eu era sombra era mais ou menos assim
como é que pode duas irmãs tão
diferentes é a mais velha tão falante
tão querida é a gravar pra mim ea outra
desse jeito
a outra tinha nome era outro
assim a gente tem não sabe que vai dar
isso né
era mais ou menos então a minha irmã
sandy também olha essa foto é meia hora
que bem a minha vontade eu vi que eu
estava ali não né mas ela mesma genica
na minha folga minha primeira comunhão
mas aí é outro problema a minha raiva
não era só da mesma regra de mim o mesmo
caso dos meus dentes
eu não sabia o que era sorrir eu não
sabia o que era ser simpática porque eu
tinha falhas nos dentes
a falha ou amadores a madonna né mãe
dona lindu o meu caminho um cigarro no
meio gospel do banho o que é isso do meu
deus como é que eu vou sorrir como uma
namorada como é que eu vou eu tenho uma
única frase que o técnico fez rumar essa
situação aqui ó cara não sorria recado
que fazer com tudo isso o volume
vitimismo eu vou achar culpado eu achar
um culpado eu vou virar esse jogo e
resolvi virar africano tomar uma decisão
tudo eu vou dizer sim
a chama para tal coisa levanta a mão aí
vou deixá la plata coisa eu vou fugir
disso vão embora fazer dígitos e tarefas
de busca também pode acabar mas a fifa
exige no bairro por bairro acampar
equipar
agora vamos pensar um mês a nossa caixa
luau que isso comecei a dançar você
gostar e aí percebi que realmente a
dança começou a jogar a interagir
instrutora grupo de dança palco do
festival de dança dos anos inclusive eu
comecei a me apaixonar
comecei a ver com a dança me trouxe
expressividade então essa postura
ela me trouxe improviso porque eu errava
demais
eu era mais desastrado ataque mas errava
era eu
só que aí precisou mandar embora eu
tenho pena de mim que era esforçado dinh
a esforçar dinha e instalaram-se
tabuleta negócio é o seguinte victor e
rato só sorri e continua pré é isso tá
bom né
eu comecei rafael cortez dá certo você
não sabe quando é que eu sei que estou
errando estava todo meu programa sorri
continue que quando falou ao microfone a
austra não foi isso que me ajudou estava
numa programação já sorria e continue
e foi assim que eu queria muito mais eu
queria buscar novas alternativas
eu queria realmente é que a dança
fizesse parte da minha vida realmente é
e pudesse buscar a outras situações
e aí eu fui eu sim pra ser voluntária
olha meu grupo de amigos falou a gente
está indo pro grupo pode ser voluntário
numa entidade jovens líderes
empreendedores onde a missão é criar
mudanças positivas eu falei em mudança
eu quero isso você se casa tudo tem que
ficar do lado uma galera diferenciada
que tem sempre uma frase que dizia assim
junto dos bancos mas fica pior foi então
eu preciso trabalhar e ficar é
diferenciada
fui então na jc ea jc e foi determinada
na reunião falou assim quem quiser fazer
um concurso de oratória levante a mão a
disputar um concurso e eu nem sabia que
era só tem meu sim ele pode descobrir
que isso mudou minha vida
foram dois anos
intensos dois anos de muito estudo e eu
voltei com o troféu na mão
feliz da vida é eu tinha tomado uma não
eu tinha tomado uma decisão
algumas coisas não fazem mais sentido
porque às vezes quando você você não
sabe o que quer da vida mas você é bom
saber que você não quer
eu não queria mais aquela faculdade eu
tranquei a faculdade no dia seguinte que
houve na áustria no dia seguinte a pedir
demissão do meu trabalho e me chamaram
de louca eu quero novas experiências ea
experiência mais competitivo na minha
vida foi ser empreendedora eu não fiz
transição de carreira eu não estudei o
mercado de palestras o que era muito
mais do que ser palestrante
abrir uma empresa não saber nada da
questão tributária de uma empresa é eu
não fiz e não fizer uma adaptação não
tive nenhum tempo simplesmente de
empregada pra ir pra empresa
empreendedora do dia pra noite eu vou
viver isso e fui aprendendo da melhor
forma possível eu fui aprendendo na
prática foi incrível e mais um sim fazer
um programa de televisão sabe que a
gravar editar não tinha manejo com
câmera foi aprendendo na prática
apresenta esse programa durante sete
anos e foi incrível aprendizado mais um
sim mais uma experiência e percebi que
estava no auge quando a minha mãe
gostava que havia no muro e avisa
perguntou assim ó abreu do rone a que
cali na fase antes do concurso
eu trabalhava em uma escola de
massoterapia só pra lá pro parentes ea
minha mãe da minha mãe muito humildes
assim antes ela falava em uma casa de
massagens né porque pra minha mãe é isso
aí avisa pelo tom sério deve correr para
tentar ajustar a minha reputação é viver
assim e agora quer fazer buscariam
concurso minha mãe chamou pra falar com
você agora faz problema
deve ser pessoa nossa inep não foi calma
mas a gente brigar melhor essa situação
é e então foi o programa de televisão e
aí eu fiquei como instrutora falei
caramba vamos estudar oratória eu quero
ser uma estrutura mas não quero ser mais
uma estrutura com essa estrutura
diferenciada eu quero enxergar o que
enxerga oratória diferente porque sei
nem se o time deles ou se podem vencer
também
e aí o padrão de oratória começou a me
incomodar porque comecei a ler livros
fazer cursos e e eu saía mais
traumatizada no curso que eu chegava
porque era tudo é muita regra não pode
isso não faça a mocinha no filho pra lá
você é muito esperta faltosa você fala
muito rápido você se movimenta demais eu
tenho que fazer
não pode não pode não pode ele começou a
me incomodar eu disse eu estava
incomodada eu estava me sentindo
ameaçado aqui na frente como queria
fazer o meu aluno fica à vontade como
queria fazer ele gostar de oratória eu
comecei ampliar o conhecimento foi
preciso e outras ferramentas da
psicologia neurociência programação e
linguística coaching é grana você juntar
essas peças porque eu queria de verdade
poder encontrar uma resposta à resposta
para saber porque é que o medo de falar
em público tá no podium porque a
oratória está como inimiga porque
oratória leva essa fama eu queria
entender profundamente isso a eu comecei
a encontrar algumas há algumas respostas
e eu percebi que o meu falar em público
é porque a gente não fala do verdadeiro
medo que a gente tem aqui na frente o
jogo e fala assim
lena tem número ser rejeitado eu tenho
medo que não se aceita
eu tenho medo do vexame eu tenho medo do
julgamento e tenho medo do ridículo
ninguém fala isso não tem medo de falar
em público embora de falar em público e
vários outros medos e interagindo e é
isso que é magnífico porque quando se
trabalha oratória você está trabalhando
outros medos que talvez seja o medo do
julgamento que vai te ajudar na vida
então comecei a me apaixonar por isso
porque eu percebi que quando você fala
assim em minha meta é a pessoa entrar no
meu curso
elas saíram mais empoderadas corajosa
para a vida e para a oratória também
porque quando se fica corajoso
você fica corajoso para a vida é isso
que comecei a mudar
eu percebi que não era eu que não se
trabalha só o medo nas pessoas durante
que trabalhará em mim
a aceitação eu tinha que me aceitar e só
com as fases mais difíceis aceitar com
os minhas limitações
os meus defeitos aceitar que quando a
gente está aqui na frente
uns vão gostar de você e outros não
está tudo bem está tudo bem isso é
libertador
eu tive que aceitar o meu jeitão estrago
você não tem de pedir que saiam para
subir e se pode você não tem idéia não
tem idéia se a sonhar com isso caindo
foi vai realizar no mínimo está tudo bem
né
vou ficar famosa deve ter caído pode
estar mas vamos lá né
tudo certo aceitava que eu sou muito
desastrada francesa chega tava arrasando
de que as pessoas vão puxando eu percebi
que o meu casaco com uma vez né me
afoguei com água já deixou o microfone
já tem um tom baixo mas um bastão
medonho eu entrei pisei no palco e até a
cabeça levantei pronta e todo mundo
rindo da minha cara eu respirei o tema
pescoço falei negócio é o seguinte cada
um entra do jeito que acha melhor
e aqui ó avançar porque na vida real
também vai mexer mas você tem que
aprender e muita já ninguém aparece
inteira então eu percebi que não ao erro
porque você vai errar você vai vai vai
ter problemas aqui na frente que você
não controla nada mas é como você reage
então eu percebi que a minha principal
técnica é o seguinte deu merda fingir a
demência mascaram cara e tá tudo bem né
a gente está jogando no branco face ã o
das pessoas não sabe se você é [ __ ]
se você é simpática ficou na dúvida e
isso é ótimo então percebi que eu tinha
que fazer algo diferente é ser
libertadora sei
ao meu jeitão porque hora para não pode
matar nossa identidade
a oratória não pode matar o que a nossa
marca aquilo que faz a gente se destacar
na natureza porque não tem padrão padrão
é você
esse é o verdadeiro padrão eu percebi
que o meu legado de oratória me deu a
resposta do porquê que eu nasci
relatório de uma resposta de ajudar de
verdade as pessoas do que o meu legado é
esse medo aqui realmente ser trocado por
uma coisa muito melhor
a leveza e alegria o amor e aceitação é
isso que é fantástico na oratória porque
enquanto não for prazeroso quanto é
prazeroso
você não precisa de técnica aqui na
frente porque é prazeroso e divertido
mas as teclas técnicas naturalmente os
olhos vão brilhar
você tem um propósito é isso que conta
em cada um com seu jeitão a maravilha
está no jeitão de cada um e é esse o meu
pedido
no meu tex da minha vida eu acordo todos
os dias realmente fazendo um pedido para
as pessoas nos ajude mesmo tirar esse
medo do podium a trocar por outra escola
por atirar se medo e mostrar que a
moratória é a oportunidade aceites
desafios pego seu negativo pega aquilo
que mais dói transforma em força
pegue aquele tão ridículo e brinque com
o atuador faça voluntariado deixa sua
marca deixa a tua identidade
o mundo esperando você está esperando as
suas ideias esperando o seu manifesto ea
oratória vai te ajudar a ser realmente
protagonista e esse é o meu verdadeiro
convite pra gente parar o que a gente
não quer
não quero dar branco não quer travar não
quer fazer feio eu não quero ouvir de
mim mas o que você quer se falar com
confiança vou trabalhar pra isso você
quer dar um show você quer falar com o
propósito você quer que a sua mensagem
chega na no coração das pessoas trabalha
se muito positivo
eu percebi que enquanto a gente não
mudar uma de 7 do oratório que é uma
oportunidade que é bom pra você
nenhuma técnica vai te ajudar porque já
tem uma campanha e saber como é a
campanha lá faz o coraçãozinho se pra
mim vá sorria e fala-se bem alto eu não
falar em público pode ser alargada e não
em público
para chegar lá o quanto mais gente
melhor andar centro das atenções
leia mais em mentira uma profetisa uma
hora vai ser verdade começa a acreditar
começa a parar de colocar a história
como vilã e começa a fazer as pazes com
você mesmo
basta fazer as pazes com o palco do s
fazer as pazes com o microfone para você
ter vez e voz e eu percebi que eu não tô
sozinha essa entidade que participou
ontem um projecto oratória nas escolas
nós vamos oratória para as crianças
o concurso de oratória em vários estados
do país em joinville
nós temos um grande ganho esse ano
levamos uma aula de oratória o ano
inteiro mas para as escolas é municipais
onde eu trago essa capacitação dos
professores de português porque o
relatório tem que começar cedo muito
cedo então nosso objetivo realmente é
buscar essa mudança de cada um fazer a
sua parte a gente chegar à oratória como
algo positivo a gente se permitir ao
nosso ridículo nosso jeitão ao nosso
medo de errar
então se você quer ser protagonista da
sua vida
se você quer vencer e subir nesse pódio
está esperando por você comece agora
comece logo e que a comunicação
realmente faça a diferença na sua vida
hoje eu estou aqui e amanhã pode ser
você
muito obrigado
[Música]